حذر تقرير للامم المتحده من تاكل سلطه
الحكومه الشرعيه في اليمن خلال العام
الجاري مشيرا الى ان المجلس الانتقالي في
الجنوب ينافس سلطه الحكومه الضعيفه
والغائب كما وصفها التقرير الذي ابد ايضا
قلقا من وجود تهديدات جديده لامن الملاحه
في باب المندب والبحر
الاحمر
السلام عليكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش
فيما
وراءه كيف وصلت الحكومه الشرعيه اليمنيه
الى وضع باتت فيه سلطتها موضع شك وتساؤل
وما تاثير هذا المعطى على الامن الاقليمي
والملاحه في البحر الاحمر وباب
المندب تكسرت قاعده دعم الرئيس اليمني عبد
ربو منصور هادي بدرجه كبيره بفعل
الانقسامات والاقتتال الداخلي بين
الميليشيات والفصائل التي تعمل خارج سيطره
حكومته الشرعيه هذا بعض مما خلص اليه
تقرير اممي ستناقش لجنه العقوبات الدوليه
الخاصه باليمن خلال الايام المقبله ويشير
التقرير الى ان هذا الواقع مع محدوديه اثر
ضربات التحالف الجوي على الارض يعمل على
توطيد تحالف الحوثي صالح ويفرز تهديدات
للامن في البحر الاحمر وباب المندب مع سعي
تنظيم القاعده الى تطوير قدراته فكيف ال
الوضع اليمني الى هذا الحال تقرير زياد
بركات منذ فراره لينا من صنعاء مطلع 2015
الى عدن ومنها الى السعوديه تحولت اليمن
به ومعه الى رهينه من يحمي الرئيس الناجي
من الحوثيين والهارب منهم فما عاد الرجل
يتجول في بلاده الا بحمايه من قوات
التحالف وتحديدا من السعوديين في البدايه
حيث غالبا ما يقيم في بلادهم لا في عدن
على ما يفترض برئيس يسعى لبسط شرعيته على
الارض ولاحقا اصبح من يتحكم هم
الاماراتيين وتحديدا ابو ظبي في مصير
الرجل ما يكشف عن تضارب اجندتي ايزاء
اليمن الاولى سعوديه وهدفها تامين حمايه
حدودها الجنوبيه ليس اكثر والثانيه تتبع
مشروعا اعرض لما اصبحت تسمى باسبار
الصغيره اي ابو
ظبي ويهدف المشروع الى احكام القبضه على
الجنوب اليمني باثره لاهداف اصبحت تتكشف
يوما بعد اخر ولا علاقه لها من قريب او
بعيد باعاده الشرعيه بل باستغلالها كشعار
لتمرير ما هو اسوا لليمن وابعد واعقد لابو
ظبي وهو احكام القبضه على الموانئ من دبي
الى عدن مرورا بالمخا وسواها ليتسنى لها
اي لابو الظبي ذلك بدات بضرب شركائها في
التحالف العربي من تحت الحزام ابتعدت عن
استراتيجيه الرياضه المفترضه وبدات بقضم
شرعيه الرئيس الذي يفترض ان تحميه
السعوديه وتناصر ما هو سياسي يتقدم هنا
لذلك شرعت باحلال قيادات مكان اخرى خلقت
رجالاتها في عدن على حساب رجالات الشرعيه
دفعت ب دروس الزبيدي وهاني بن بريك الى
الواجهه فشكل مجلسا لاداره الجنوب وقيدت
حركه وزراء ورجالات هادي ووصل الامر بها
الى محاوله منع الرئيس نفسه من الهبوط في
مطار عدن لماذا تفعل ابو ظبي ذلك لعلها
النزعه الامبراطوريه تراودها وتكشف
مشروعها الكبير في المنطقه تتشارك مع هذا
الرجل في اعلاء العسكره على مدنيه
المجتمعات وفي اليمن فعل ذلك ضاربه عرض
الحائض بانتقادات حقوقيه دوليه فانشات
سجونا سريه واعتقلت وعذبت وشردت وما ذلك
الا لتمهد الطريق لمشروعها وهو السيطره
بدايه وصلت قواتها الى باب المندب ف ميناء
عدن الاستراتيجي ف ميناء المخا وعينها على
الحديده ما يعني الهيمنه على الموانئ
والتحكم في حركه مرور التجاره الدوليه
وتكييفها لصالحها وهو ما يفسر تركيزها على
مدن اليمن الساحليه اكثر من غيرها ويعتقد
ان اسبارتا الصغيره تسعى الى دفع عمان الى
الوراء في هذا المجال تحديدا وتحويل موانئ
الامارات الى مركز تتفرع عنه بقيه موانئ
المنطقه فتتح بها وتشل بعضها وتفعل اخرى
وصولا الى موانئ الصوماليه وذاك مشروع
كبير قد تنوء تحت ثقله دوله الامارات
باسرها وقد تدفع ثمنه لاحقا هنا في اليمن
تمتحن سبارتا الصغيره فاذا ابو ظبي قوه
احتلال كما يصفها البعض لا تعنيها الشرعيه
ولا السكان ولا ارث البلاد العريق وتلك
توصف بغطس المحتل حين يستهين بالتاريخ فلا
يتعلم
منه نرحب بضيوفنا في هذه الحلقه من
اسطنبول الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اليمني
نبيل البكيري من لندن الباحث السياسي
اليمني احمد المؤيد ومن رام الله عبد
الحميد الصيام الخبير في شؤون الامم
المتحده نبدا من اسطنبول والسيد البكيري
ما الذي اوصل الشرعيه في اليمن الى هذا
التاكل وفق تعبير التقرير
الاممي لا شك انه الشرعيه بعد عامين
واربعه اشهر من قيام عاصفه الحزم كان
يفترض انها تكون في مكان
في وضع اكثر قوه وتماسكا مما هي فيه اليوم
لكن للاسف هناك سببان رئيسيا باعتقادي سبب
تراجع او تاكل الشرعيه كما وصف تقرير
الامم المتحده ويرجع بالدرجه الرئيسيه هذا
التراجع والتاكل الى اولا سبب ذاتي كانا
منهم في عدم انسجام فريق الشرعيه وتضارب
اجندات بعض اطراف هذا الفريق الذي ايضا
يخضع الاستقطابات بين عاصمتي اي قياده
التحالف ابو ظبي والرياض والسبب الرئيسي
والجوهري ايضا وهو السبب الذي ربما يسبق
ما ذكرته سابقا وهو تضارب الاجندات او
بمعنى اخر كواليس ما يسمى بالتحالف العربي
وبعض اطراف هذا التحالف العربي ممثله
بالامارات العربيه المتحده ولايه ابو ظبي
او امارات ابوو ظبي تحديدا وا اجندتها
الواضحه فيما يتعلق بمسار العمليات
العسكريه في اليمن وما س ما سينشى عليها
عنها مستقبلا من وضع سياسي في اليمن حيث
سعت درجه الرئيسيه الى اضعاف الشرعيه في
جنوب اليمن و في المناطق المحرره التي تحر
تحررت جنوبا مبكرا وسعت ايضا لايجاد سلطه
بديله وخارج اطار هذه السلطه الشرعيه
ممثله بما سمي الميليشيات المسلحه التي
تسميها وتطلق عليها بالحزام الامني او
بالنخب الحضرميه او بغيرها من المسميات
التي هي في درجه في الاساس تعمل كبديل على
الارض عن القوات الرسميه التابعه لوزاره
الداخليه الشرعيه وايضا للجيش ال اليمني
وبالتالي هذ الا الى جانب هذين الى جانب
هذين
العامين يعني اسمح لي سيد البكيري الى
جانب هذين العاملين عدم انسجام صف الشرعيه
والتضارب في اجندات وكواليس التحالف
العربي هل يمكن سيد عبد الحميد الصيام ان
يكون ايضا من بين اسباب التاكل ان الامم
المتحده ووساطات في هذا الملف لم تكن
بالحزم
الضروري الذي يمكن ان يوصل الى تطبيق
قرارات الامميه الخاصه باستعاده
الشرعيه مساء الخير لك ولضيوفك الكرام
احييكم من رام الله في البدايه واتمنى لكم
وقتا طيبا اهلا وسهلا بالنسبه لمساله
اليمن الامم المتحده احست منذ وقت بان
شرعيه عبد ربو منصور هادي بدات تتاكل وقد
قدم السيد اسماعيل ولد الشيخ احمد تاريخ
29 اكتوبر
2016 خارطه الطريق جديده تتعارض مع
الخارطه الاصليه التي نص عليها القرار
221 القرار 22/1 يبدا من نزع سلاح
المليشيات وتجميع الاسلحه خارطه الطريق
التي بداها او اقترحها السيد ولد الشيخ
احمد تبدا من تعيين حكومه وحده وطنيه
وتعيين رئيس وزراء ويكون منصب الرئيس رئيس
الجمهوريه عبد ربو منصور دي منصبا ش شرفيا
وبالتالي رفض هذه الشرعيه ورفض هذه
الخارطه حاولت الامم المتحده جهدها وعقدت
عده عده جلسات في سويسرا وفي الكويت لكن
اذا كانت الاطراف المعنيه اساسا غير
قادرين على ان يتوصلوا الى ارضيه مشتركه
لا تستطيع الامم المتحده ان تفرض عليهم حق
حلا ياتي في مظله تنزل عليهم من السماء
كانت المواقف متباعده كان اعضاء التحالف
يعتقدون انهم سيحسم المعركه عسكريا وكذلك
الاطراف الاخرى الحوثييون و حزب المؤتمر
كانوا ايضا يعتقدون انهم هم على الارض
اقوى ويستطيعون ان يحسموا المعركه عسكريا
لذلك تباعدت المسالك ولم يكن هناك ارضيه
مشتركه تستطيع الامم المتحده ان تجمع بين
الطرفين لذلك قدم ولد الشيخ احمد خارطه
طريق جديده تبدا
بتشكيل وحده حكومه وحده وطنيه
مكونه من الطرفين
الاساسيين التحالف من جهه وعبد رب منصور
طبعا و الحوثيون وحلفائهم من حزب المؤتمر
طبعا
هذه هذه الخارطه رفضت وتصرف عبد ربو منصور
هادي بعدما و احس ان هناك تشكيكا في
شرعيته تصرفا لم يكن يخدمه بالتحديد فقد
قام بطرد
مثلا رئيس بلديه عدن ثم قام ايضا مؤخرا في
29 حزيران بطرد ثلاث حكام من ولايات
الجنوب وبدا يتصرف
بطريقه ايضا بطريقه عشوائيه على ذكر على
ذكر على ذكر الرئيس عبد الربو منصور هادي
على ذكر الرئيس عبد الربو منصور هادي اشرت
الى هذه القرارات التي تمت وخرج البعض
واسس المجلس الانتقالي في في الجنوب سيد
احمد
المؤيد هذا انشاء هذا المجلس وبقا الرئيس
عبد الربو منصور هادي معظم الوقت في
الرياض وليس في على ارض الوطن هل سهم
بدوري في تاكل
شرعيه الحكومه
اليمنيه نعم ليس المجلس السياسي فقط نحن
عندما نتحدث عن تاكل شرعيه هادي يجب ان
ننظر هل هناك شرعيه من الاساس او لا هادي
لا يمتلك اي سلطه شرعيه
ففترة سيد مؤيد يعني الا المعارضين له
يطعنون في هذا الموضوع لكن على الصعيد
الدولي على الصعيد القرارات الدوليه عبد
ربو منصور هادي يمثل الحكومه الشرعيه
الطعن هذا الذي تشير اليه
فقط من داخل اليمن داخل ال الا الرغبه
السعوديه لا يوجد له شرعيه الا الرغبه
السعوديه
فيات والقرارات الدوليه لا تنس هناك
والقرارات الدوليه سيدي الكريم هناك هناك
ت تاثير للسعوديه وقوى النفوذ السياسي
العالمي التي ترى ان في مصلحتها او التي
تبحث عن مصلحتها في اليمن في الهيمنه عليه
ترى انها تحتاج الى مثل هذا الشخص الضعيف
الذي لا شرعيه له وبالتالي يعني لا يمت
الى المساله الوطنيه بصله لان القوى
الوطنيه لو كانت هناك قوه وطنيه على الارض
ا فلن تسمح باي هيمنه لا سعوديه ولا
اماراتيه ولا تمرير مثل هذه مثل هذا
العدوان او هذه القرارات وبالتالي نحن
اصلا لا نعترف بشرعيه هذه من حيث الاساس
فالرجل هو اول من عرف ان فترته انتهت وذهب
ومدد لنفسه لا دستوريا عن طريق رئاسه مجلس
الحوار الوطني التي لا تمتلك ان تمدد
للرئيس فترته وبالتالي بعد ان انتهى يعني
بعد ان انتهت مدته تدخلت السعوديه بعدوانه
في اليمن وارادت ان تخلط الاوراق لان جمال
بن عمر في احاطته في 25 ابريل قال ان
الاطراف السياسيه اليمنيه كانت قد اتفقت
على كل البنود ولم يبقى الا مساله الرئاسه
وبالتالي تدخل العدوان لكي لا تحسم هذه
المساله فمجيء قوى وطنيه الى صنعاء ال الى
سده الحكم ستقطع ستقطع اذرع الهيمنه
السعوديه وهذا ما لا تريده السعوديه
بالتالي بحثت عن هذه وجدته قد فر الى عمان
فجاءت به وقالت سنعيد شرعيه هذا الرئيس
ومن هناك بدا العدوان ولانه لا شرعيه له
ولا يستطيع اصلا التواجد في المناطق التي
يدعي انه يسيطر عليها نجد انه قابع في
فنادق الرياض منذ سنتين ونصف حتى حكومته
واعضاء يعني ادارته كلهم في الرياض من
هناك يصدرون يعني قراراتهم من داخل غرفهم
في الفنادق الشرعيه يا سيدي الكريم هي ما
موجوده في صنعاء الان ت تجد الرئيس علي
عبد الله صالح موجود في الجبهات وموجود
حتى في الاسواق العامه تجد محمد علي
الحوتي رئيس اللجنه الثوريه في الجبهات
وتجده حتى على موتر سيكل في الشارع بشكل
طبيعي تجد صالح الصماد في الجبهات وتجده
في جيزان يشرف على عمليات الجيش واللجان
الشعبيه واذا دعوا الى مظاهره او فعاليه
رفضتهم الملايين بحيث لا تستطيع الكاميرا
ان تغطيها من زاويه واحده هذه هي الشرعيه
الحقيقيه سبب اخر يعني هل هناك سبب اخر
سيد نبيل البكيري وهو موضوع الموارد
الماليه عندما عندما تكون هذه الحكومه
الشرعيه وفق القرارات الدوليه مره اخرى
اؤكد على هذه النقطه الهامه الحكومه
والشرعيه في اليمن مكرسه بقرارات دوليه
هذه هذه نقطه يجب ان تكون واضحه في هذا
النقاش سيد نبيل بكيري هل ايضا غياب
الموارد الماليه عن هذه الحكومه لا البنك
المركزي تسيطر عليه لا الموانئ و مداخيل
هذه الموانع تسيطر عليها فبالطبع لا تملك
الموارد الماليه
اللازمه
بدايه دعني بس ارد على الاخ جاوبني على
السؤال الله يخليك جاوبني على السؤال
جاوبني على السؤال وبعدين بعدين رد جاوبني
على هذه النقطه وبعدين رد على انا
باعتقادي ايضا انه تفضل ق موضوع الموارد
الماليه انا باعتقادي ليست سببا رئيسيا في
تضعضع الشرعيه اليوم الموارد الرئيسيه
الموارد الرئيسيه الموجوده انا باعتقادي
انه جز لا باس به يمضي اليوم و ويؤدي
خدمات او بمعنى يغطي تكاليف معظم ال
المصالح الحكوميه التي تدار الاشكاليه في
عدم عوده الحكومه الى الداخل عدم تمكن
الحكومه من العوده الى العاصمه المؤقته
عدن هذه انا باعتقادي سبب جوهري في تضعضع
وفشل فريق الشرعيه في هذه المرحله اما
الجانب المالي انا باعتقادي انه ممكن
تجاوزه بشكل كبير حينما يتم ضبط ايرادات
مؤسسات الدوله العامله كماني عدن ومواني
المكله ايضا المطارات المناطق المحرره
ايضا الغاز والنفط معظم معظم هذا الغاز
والنفط الان تحت سيطره الحكومه الشرعيه
انا باعتقادي ليست المساله مساله موارد
ماليه بقدر ما تتعلق بعدم وجود اراده
سياسيه حقيقيه لدى الحكومه الشرعيه ايضا
وايضا وجود ايضا العامل المتمثل بالتحالف
العربي واجندات الامارات العربيه المتحده
التي تقود التحالف اليوم في اليمن وليس
المملكه العربيه السعوديه يعني هذه معلومه
اقدمها لكم اليوم من يقود التحالف في
اليمن هي المم هي الامارات وليس المملكه
التي تراجعت بسبب الانشغال بملفات الحكم
في الداخل ربما هذا ربما هذا الوضع الذي
تشير اليه ربما هذا الوضع الي ربما نعم
يعني ربما هذا الوضع الذي تشير اليه تقدم
دوله الامارات على السعوديه في التحالف
العربي هو الذي جعلها مثل ما تابعنا في
التقرير تقريبا تسيطر على كل موانا اليمن
ووضعها في جنوب البلاد يكاد يكون قوه
مستقله كامله عن ايه شرعيه موجوده في
اليمن لهذا نريد ان ان نتطرق بعد الفاصل
الى تاثير تاكل سلطه الحكومه الشرعيه في
اليمن على الامن الاقليمي والملاحه تحديدا
في البحر الاحمر وباب الندم لن
[موسيقى]
عوده
اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نناقش فيها ابعاد تحذير الامم
المتحده من تاكل سلطه الحكومه الشرعيه في
اليمن ومن وجود تهديدات لامن الملاحه في
باب المندب والبحر الاحمر السيد عبد
الحميد
السيام اشرنا الى نقطه عدم انسجام التحالف
العربي وضيفنا من اسطنبول يقول الان دوله
الامارات عمليا هي التي تقود التحالف
العربي وليس السعوديه الان عندما تسيطر
دوله الامارات على الموانئ بشكل رئيسي
في اليمن وهي التي جاءت لانقاذ الشرعيه
فاذا بها تتحول الى قوه خارج هذا السياق
ما الذي يمكن ان يؤثر مثل هذا الوضع
نعم
يعني انا لا ارى ان هناك تحالفا عربيا
الان هناك مجموعه قوى كل تعمل لمصلحتها
وهذا سينعكس على وضع اليمن اليمن الان
اقرب الى الدوله الفاشله من الممكن جدا ان
تتفكك اليمن هناك 19 مليون لا يجدون قوتهم
يوميا هناك انتشار مرض الكور الكوليرا
وهذا فرصه مناسبه لجماعه القاعده وداعش ان
تنتشر اكثر ايضا هناك تهديد للملاحه كما
حدث و اطلق اطلقت النيران على السفن
العابره لمضيق باب المندب اذا الوضع في
اليمن مثالي للانفجارات والى التهديدات
الاقليميه للامن الاقليمي في المنطقه
وتعزيز الجماعات الارهابيه تماما واذا لم
يكن هناك حل ازمه اليمن وهي اكبر ازمه
انسانيه في العالم حسب تقرير صدر يوم امس
من ثلاث منظمات انسانيه اكبر كارثه
انسانيه في العالم الان في اليمن فهي وضع
مثالي تماما لتفكك اليمن وانتشار القاعده
والجماعات الارهابيه والتي ستؤثر على
المنطقه
برمتها مما ورد في في التقرير سيد احمد
المؤيد الخوف على الملاحه الدوليه موضوع
باب المندب موضوع البحر الاحمر يعني هل هل
تعتقد
بان هذه القوه التي جاءت ضمن التحالف
العربي دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده
سيطرتها الان على هذه الموانع هل لديك اي
تفسير لهذا الت وجه من قبل الامارات في
اليمن سيدي الامارات الان تعتبر هي الرابح
الاكبر في من قوى العدوان على اليمن لان
لها هدفا واضح وهي تسعى اليه هدف الامارات
هي ان تسعى الى السيطره على على ميناء عدم
بالدرجه الاولى وان لا يقع في ايدي وطنيه
لان هذا الميناء اذا وقع في ايدي وطنيه
سيتم تطويره وبالتالي سيسحب الاضواء من
دبي بشكل كامل وستصبح حركه الملاحه
الاقتصاديه بين الشرق والغرب في تلك
النقطه وبالتالي يجب السيطره عليها بشكل
تام الان من يهدد الملاحه البحريه هي
الامارات التي احتلت جزيره ميون ميون تقع
في حلق باب المندب وانشات هناك قاعده
عسكريه هذا هو اكبر تهديد لحركه الملاحه
في المنطقه او في في في خط الملاحه
التجاريه في باب المندب الامارات تسعى الى
السيطره على الموانئ لكي تعزز وجودها في
الجنوب وبالتالي عهدت الى بعض القوه التي
تمولها وتنشئه وتعمل سجون سريه وتعمل
ميليشيات خاصه وتحاول ان توازن
بينها يعني بالنسبه لما تسمى شرعيه هادي
في الجنوب سقطت سقوطا تاما ولم تعد
متواجده اصلا ويوجد هناك مشروع اماراتي
دافعه الهيمنه هي الان تسيطر على جزيره
سقطره و يعني صادرت منها بعض المواد
الاثريه وتنشئ فيها هناك مطارات واضافه
الى الى انها ترفض عملياتها العسكريه من
ميناء عصب في ارتيريا وبالتالي المنطقه او
حركه الملاحه في تلك المنطقه كلها مهدده
نتيجه ال الاكن الهن الهيمنه سيد مؤيد لاي
لاي هدف لاي
هدف الهدف يا سيدي بالنسبه للامارات هو
ميناء عدن هذا الميناء يجب ان يبقى في
ايدي عميله للامارات حتى لا يتطور لانه
ميناء يعني بالطبيعه وبالتالي لو تحسن هذا
الميناء قدرته الانتاجيه والملاحيه اصبحت
على مستوى عالي سيسحب الاضواء من دبي لانه
سيصبح هو على الطريق المباشر ما بين طري
طريق الملاحه بين الشرق والغرب وبالتالي
من مصلحه الامارات ان ينفصل الجنوب وهي
تسعى لذلك وهي دعمت المجلس السياسي الذي
كل قادته هم عباره عن دم تمولهم الامارات
وينشطون وقت ما تريد ويخفت صوتهم وقت ما
تريد الامارات بالتالي السعوديه الان
اصبحت تائهه في في مثل هذا الجو وال
الرابح الاكبر الان هو الامارات ا يعني
بالنسبه للقوى الوطنيه في صنعاء او في
يعني اي قوى وطنيه على على الارض على فكره
حتى في الجنوب يرفضون كل هذا العمل
الاماراتي يرفضون كل هذه التواجد اللا
شرعيه هذا احتلال بكل معنى الكلمه ويعزز
الانقسامات وربما يعني تتشظى اليمن نتيجه
هذا السلوك العدواني الاحتلالي في اليمن
التي الذي تنتهجه الامارات نعم ه هذا
الامر الواقع سيد نبيل البكيري كيف يمكن
ان ان يتطور لاحقا لان اذا فرض هذا الامر
الواقع حتى لو عادت الشرعيه حتى لو لم
ينفصل جنوب ال في دوله مستقله كما يريد
اهالي الجنوب ويقولون هذا الامر لن لن
يعود كما كان على
الاقل لازال ل لدى الشرعيه العديد من
الاوراق التي ممكن ان ان ان توقف هذا
العبث الاماراتي في اليمن ايضا القوى
الوطنيه المخلصه التي لا تدخل ضمن مفهوم
الطغاه الذين يقلبون الغزاء وهي تنطبق
بدرجه رئيسيه على الميليشيات الانقلابيه
الطائفيه التي تعمل كاذ ايرانيه في اليمن
انا باعتقادي انه المستفيد الاول والاخير
مما يحدث في اليمن هو المشروع الايراني
للاسف الذي يتم خدمه هذا المشروع من قبل
الاجندات الاماراتيه التي تمتلك علاقات
وثيقه مع النفوذ الايراني في اليمن من
خلال العلاقه القائمه بين الميليشيات
الانفصاليه المسلحه اليوم التي تكون او
تشكل ما يسمى بالمجلس الجنوبي الانتقالي
وبين المليشيات الطائفيه الحاكمه في صنعاء
هناك رابط وخيط يربط بين هذين ال ال
الميليشيات من خلال التدريب الذي تم
تدريبهم به من خلال الضاحيه الجنوبيه ومن
خلال خبراء حزب الله الذين اشتغلوا خلال
الفتره الماضيه في تدريب هذه الميليشيات
سواء في الجنوب او الشمال وبالتالي انا
باعتقادي انه المستفيد الوحيد من ما يجري
في اليمن من ادوات المشروع الاماراتي او
بمعنى اخر من العبث الاماراتي في اليمن هو
المشروع الايراني الذي اصبح اليوم يمتلك
قوه حكم نافذه في الجنوب والشمال على حد
سواء وبالتالي انا باعتقادي الخطر الكبير
اليوم قائم من
عدم وجود او اغفال او فشل المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في لملمه المشهد اليمني
واعاده الشرعيه الى مكانها ورفد هذه
الشرعيه بالادوات الحقيقيه لاداره الصراع
او لاداره المرحله في اليمن وهي الكفيله
فقط في ايقاف هذا العبث من قبل
الميليشيات العامله خارج اطار الدوله
اليمنيه والسياده الوطنيه ايقاف الفراغ
الامن نعم تهديد نعم يعني معذر على
المقاطعه باختصار شديد سيد عبد الحميد
السياد تهديد الملاحه هل سيجعل الامم
المتحده اكثر حماسه
للتسويه يعني الامم المتحده الان تعيش
حقيقه في مازق فقد اخذ الحوثيون قرارا
بعدم التعامل مع السيد اسماعيل ولد الشيخ
احمد هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى ايضا صدرت
احكام بالاعدام لبعض من في صنعاء
لرموز ما يسمى الشرعيه منهم عبد رب و
منصور هادي اذا الاوضاع التي تعيشها الامم
المتحده الان وضع صعب وقد يتم تغييرات لكن
اذا كان هناك اطراف معينه تريد ان تعمل
على تسويه حقيقيه في اليمن فعليها ان تاتي
الى الطاوله الامم المتحده جاهزه للعوده
الى المفاوضات لكن مره اخرى هناك خارطه
طريق جديده تبدا ب حكومه وحده وطنيه
وتنتقل الى موضوع نزح الاسلحه وتجميعها
والان قال الى الدستور والى الانتخابات
شكرا لك عبد الحميد سيام الخبير في شؤون
الامم المتحده شكرا لضيفنا من لندن الباحث
السياسي اليمني احمد المؤيد وللضيف من
اسطنبول الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اليمني
نبيل البكيري بهذا نصل الى نهايه هذه
الحلقه في امان
الله
ه